mm-hmm
well well well guys what is up welcome
to the just pearly things YouTube
channel and welcome
I don't have a name for this segment but
I'll just say reactions with pearl today
we are going to be reacting to
this man House of hypocrites
who has broken the internet okay he has
broken the internet now
let me oh wait let me turn off my sound
something's excited you okay
um let me show you guys the video that
has been taking the Internet by storm I
was sent this to so many of you
by so many of you okay let me
and I want you guys to put your take on
this in the comments okay I got seven
kids and seven baby mamas now for the
past few days I've been going live
telling my story speaking my truth and a
lot of women having the issue calling me
a deadbeat because I tell them I was
being irresponsible yeah not wearing
protection but I always tell these women
that I got pregnant that I do not want
to be a father to these children and I
offer to pay for the abortion majority
of times they'll either take the
abortion or they'll take a plan B but
only these seven have kept these
children but the crazy thing about it is
they want me to be responsible for some
children I told them I did not want so
for some years now some of them been
trying to get in contact with me access
denied because I don't really know why
you trying to get in contact with me I
didn't told you I did not want them kids
so don't expect me to be responsible
financially emotional spiritual mentally
or physically with some kids I do not
want and I don't give a [__] when nobody
think about it you're not going to force
children up on me yet we both made the
decision to lay down and have
intercourse we both was irresponsible
about the decisions we made that night
yeah I could have pulled out but I
didn't and I ain't caterpillar because
I'm not the one that gonna have to carry
a baby for nine months it's the woman in
my opinion women should be more careful
on who they sleep with because you're
gonna be like one of my baby mamas
trying to find me so I can financially
support a kid I didn't told her or them
I did not want them another thing is
these just jump offs he's the type of
woman that I ain't even have to do
nothing for the bad minimum but they
gave me access to their body and they
think I want to be a father to a child
for one of them wait I don't even have
no type of love for these women how do
they expect me to love these children
but for you I say oh he irresponsible
he'll deadbeat you don't take
accountability yeah I do I just don't
give a [__] you ain't gonna Force these
children on me when I told you I ain't
want them yeah I can offer to a pay for
abortion but at what point can I force a
woman to go get an abortion I cannot a
woman say my body my choice but I say
it's my life my choice before y'all try
to stitch this [__] and be like black
men this black man that I don't give a
[__] I really don't
I got seven kids
wow seven so this video stood out to me
in particular because
um the other day I did a wife School
episode right and I did this wife School
episode and someone came up to me during
during the episode and
um the guy the guy said your content is
especially important to me
because I have six baby mothers
okay
I I don't know where
you know I never said six seven baby
mothers was a good idea but you know I
decided we should hear from the man the
myth the legend himself
um how do I share the screen you have to
show me one second one second hold on I
gotta do I oh wait I do it this way
this way okay
um welcome to Jess pearly things house
um you can unmute yourself now
what's up what's good Hi how are you
cool
okay
um so
we just watched the video you know
um so how how did you
I just have so many questions okay
oh okay tell me tell me what made you
want to make that video first
oh see um I was on Tick Tock I usually
didn't use tick tock because uh I was on
Instagram then I used to say some crazy
[__] on Instagram so they ended up
taking my uh Instagram down so I ended
up going to tick tock and uh eventually
started going live with people and then
we'll have just like the conversations
that we'll see on your show you what I'm
saying typical conversation like that
about uh this is the dynamic of the male
and female relationship uh standpoints
uh So eventually uh I guess they they
had to ask something about about kids or
something about how women
um
don't have uh well they do they have
many choices to to I guess either avoid
uh give up their rights for children or
um
adoption yeah they just have so many
different uh I have options and then I
told them I didn't have those options
and I have seven kids
by seven women that I did not want and
so and then eventually I was talking for
about I guess seven days
and um [__] I just ended up making a
video about it because everybody was
kept requesting me to come on Tick Tock
lives into to talk about it so I was
just like all right I'm gonna just go
ahead and just put it out there and put
it on wax and just
make a video and then I already knew I
already knew it was gonna do like
like you know what I'm saying viral you
know in a sense of tick tock I didn't
know that [__] was going all across the
world you feel me
[Music]
um
so
sorry
how old do your youngest kid
I think four four okay so you've another
kid in four yeah that's about it
the youngest year before
and that woman was married
okay
um do you pay child support at all
no not at all how how do you not
you gotta you gotta know my name and you
gotta know where I live and you gotta
know where I work
okay so none of the women actually know
your name
not at all I just give them the name t
the same one I gave you
okay
okay so basically these girls
um if they were all was it all casual
were you dating any of them
um I mean casual sex it wasn't like
you know it wasn't like a relationship
type thing it was just you know sex that
was it some some were longer than other
ones most of them was on the first day
yeah most of them was probably on the
first day next day
and did you tell them beforehand like I
don't
I don't know because in the video you
made it seem like you told them like I
don't want anything to do with these
kids like when did that conversation
come up
oh
oh we you know when you're releasing a
woman man like they just and somebody
and some of them was kind of accident
and didn't know so when it when it came
up or like oh missed period I'm offering
abortions at that point
uh and if I if I didn't know I let I let
in them it's a plan B but I'm not about
to just sit there and hold your
[__] hand and watch you take a
plan B you feel me so it's just like
it's just it's just different scenarios
and this is seven out of the ten
three of them the other three actually
you know got an abortion see this seven
out of ten you got 10 women pregnant see
okay see I actually sort of agreed with
your video and I sort of disagreed okay
I'll tell you why so I I agreed that
like women we have all the choice and
when you're talking about how women they
don't
take accountability you know for giving
random men their body where you don't
even know their full name like that's
crazy but like how do you make the same
mistake seven or ten times
like did you never think in out of the
10 maybe it's time to start wearing
condoms maybe you know
like no I do I do work on yeah I do oh
speak speaking of comments I it was
crazy is oh I'll talk about that later I
do wear condoms I do wear condoms it's
just those seven instances are have been
Savvy unlucky ass instance
did you feel like it was intentional by
any of them
oh no no no
never never not at all because I I
wouldn't intentionally uh get a woman
pregnant no I said by them like the
women did you feel like any of them were
intentionally trying to get pregnant
because you always hear like from the
women it just happened
the ones
that
um
tried to like you know what I'm saying
reach out and like you know what I'm
saying talk about me being in the kids
uh life and [__] like that I feel like
that was like you know what I'm saying
it could have been it could have been
planned it could have been intentional I
don't I don't know I can't think or
speak for them actually you know what
I'm saying but uh I could I could go
ahead and try to blame [__] all
I want to you know I'm saying I just
know I played a part in it but I also
know they played a part in there as well
so it's just like I wouldn't say uh
intentionally it could be it could have
been
all day part or their part
yeah no I saw it I saw that what is your
response been to like the reaction the
internet's had like did you know they
were gonna
um react the way it did
uh [__] ain't nobody ever came by the
city
ain't nobody ain't nobody ever get on
the internet and basically become the
most famous [__] deadbeat ain't
nobody ever do it
I I imagine that it will have some
effect but I didn't know it would go
this far but I think a lot of men and
women resonate when they hit me in my
DMs it's mostly women saying I agree
with you you feel me it's mostly women
saying I'm a group I agree with you in
the DMS and then this other man that's
trying to hold me in accountable Batman
another black man accountable which you
can't do I have to hold myself
accountable so it's just like the
reaction is the reaction you feel me and
the backlash I don't give a [__] about
it I'm My Own man with my own boys with
my own standards you feel me I'ma stand
on my own too so this is like the
reaction it don't
well I mean I do think it was really
um
I mean it does show because a lot of
times like I talk to girls on my show
all the time that will talk about how it
just happened and they'll kind of paint
the guy as as being the bad guy but it's
like we have we have all of these
choices
um you know like you were talking about
abortion Plan B
um you can get on birth control and so
it's like
how do you how do you let a guy get you
pregnant that you don't even know
yeah and so uh I think I think I I think
I think women do better uh the vocal
responsibility because you have to allow
me to idiot that's just like you have to
allow a man interview and if you're
gonna allow him to to enter you
recklessly without protection then
there's consequences to that yeah I know
I played part two but if if you're gonna
give me the responsibility of being
responsible for your body it might be
consequences that can be that could be
anything I don't have no STDs but that
could be STDs or children
do they ever try to reach out to you
like have any of the kids ever tried to
reach out to you
I'm not uh my mind set a stone but oh I
guess a few days ago one of my uh
my uh baby mamas had reached out to me
and uh I plan to bring on one of these
shows uh but I don't think she want to
be on camera but she would like speak
and call in or something like that but
she was she was one of the baby mamas
that uh kind of understand how I think
in in a sense of we both was being
irresponsible right so and she knew the
kids she knew the consequences as well
as I did after you know what I'm saying
uh she uh found out she was pregnant and
I was like yeah I'm not ready to be a
father and she's like okay I understand
I'm not trying to push fatherhood on you
but if you ever decided you want to be a
father I'm here but she didn't want to
avoid the baby everybody thinking it's
just like it's certain it's a lot of
different scenarios that I uh I could
get into but I just give you you know a
few so it it it wasn't just like uh all
these women are just trying to force me
to be a father some women just want kids
you know what I'm saying and don't
believe in abortion I can understand
that but she she hit me up um
the other day
um and she said yeah I can kind of come
defend you if I can you know but she's
not trying to be like on camera or
anything because she is in a
relationship right now how many of them
are actively like searching for you
would you say or like trying to get
child support off of you I have I have
that's the that's the only one that I
see in my DMs I ain't getting no emails
or nothing like that but I got I
probably
is crazy
so that's probably the only one I see I
know one the married woman she not
looking for me at all so
so I guess the other five [__] I ain't
heard I haven't seen that from it or
heard nothing from him so I just meant
like our any of um
like I know you mentioned they don't
know your full name so they can't get
child support from you but I just met
um are any of them trying to get it like
actively like trying to find you showing
up have you ever had him show up at your
work like somewhere that they that they
knew you would be anything like that
no impossible
what do you mean impossible
it's impossible
I made good money though it's impossible
I don't do nothing legal but I make good
money oh okay but it's impossible yeah
okay and why why do you feel like it's
more on the women than you
oh [__] they they don't want to carry
the babies not much I don't carry kids I
could be irresponsible
I can be it's the difference between
being eagerly
irresponsible and consciously
irresponsible I'm gonna be irresponsible
seven baby mothers huh that's just so
crazy to me
um and you also I know it's a guy that I
wouldn't say his name be uh he got 15.
you know you know someone with 15.
because it's just to me I just like how
do you how does that happen that many
times like I don't understand one
you know I'll give you two but seven
seven like how do you get seven baby
mothers
crazy I didn't want seven bags they they
kept the kids yeah yeah yeah but like
you didn't know that after the first
second third time
it was over it was over a point of
[__] 17 to 27 I [__] a decade
this is a I was 17 to 27.
so it's like
one well you say 70. it's like well it's
like every other year I said by 60 years
because the national is four so yeah oh
span of six years yeah wow
it's crazy
um
man's man is
um did you learn anything from it like
do you are you more responsible now at
least do you feel like the women learned
like did they learn a lesson in it
I mean I don't I don't keep up with them
so [__] hopefully they learn the lesson
I mean but you know stuff if I repeated
it
after the first season the first time
yeah I don't know you don't know I don't
know the experience it's possible that
they learn no for sure I learned though
my last my last pregnancy scare was uh
[__] October uh 2022 and uh but this
this I actually like this female until
she said a particular thing uh I asked
her uh after seven eight weeks because I
believe I don't care if you're married I
don't care like if you've been knowing
somebody for a long time I believe you
should you should get a DNA test on your
kids right so this is the one that I was
actually like looking to keep you feel
me and uh I asked I was like oh you know
seven eight weeks I'm a uh
I want to get a DNA sex you know because
you can do it in the womb I heard that
you know what I'm saying technology
thank God so uh she was like oh that's
embarrassing and
I wouldn't do that I'd rather be a
single mother
and I never talked to her again
then take a plan B she'd rather be a
single mother
now at this point she was already like
um
she had to be like uh four to five weeks
oh wow
yeah and she was like instead of taking
a DNA test because that's embarrassing
to her she'd rather be a single mother
that only let me know [__] that could be
for somebody else why would I waste my
money to try to find out who this kid
for
um
I'm sorry
I just I just can't it's actually wild
to be there yeah it's just
this is just such a different world I
don't know a single person with like
even
two baby mothers that weren't from like
wives you know so it's like it's just
crazy that one person can have seven you
know someone who's 15.
they take troops to Jamaica to find men
like me
um
why do you think modern women are so
irresponsible with their bodies
because they have a system that would
would back their ass the [__] up
child support that different type of
welfares different type of government
assistance that that favors single
mothers so if they are irresponsible
they know there's a system that's going
to back their ass up
do you think that they would have those
women would have acted differently if
they didn't have those systems
oh yeah now I think more women to be be
actually uh actually men and marry them
before they even try to even bear a
child which it should be like that I
really I really I really think and
prefer women to you know I'm saying kind
of take in consideration the type of
dudes that you might meet because you
might need me and if I don't want you
like that and I don't like it like that
and I accidentally get you pregnant I
don't want a kid with you so I think I
think women should be more or conscious
about who the men who who which man is
they sleeping with and hold some type of
moral stainless at least have a dude
commit to you you know what I'm saying
at least if you don't believe in
marriage at least at least we just had
to do you know what I'm saying buy you a
[__] house or something you
know what I'm saying so you could have
some type of stability to raise a
[__] child so I I really
believe we should get back to this to
this uh um
Mary before you carry me type [__] it
sounds hypocritical but yeah it's not
hard to say when it's like you're
contributing in a way
yeah it is hard to say but [__] somebody
gotta learn something and the message
got to get out there even if it's from a
hypocrite yeah yeah you got to think
about the things that fast
didn't they say it's better to it's
better to uh to raise a child in a
two-pound home right yeah
do you ever feel bad do you ever feel
bad at all not even a little bit
like do you think you'd ever want to
meet any of your kids
would you ever want to meet your kids
like when they're older
nah not really but it can happen I'm not
against it but like I only have a desire
for kids that don't supposed to be here
what do you think more men
um do you think it's more common for men
to be deadbeats
um and not want to be in their kids
lives or do you think it's more common
that the mom's not letting them see the
kids
when it comes to like single parent
homes
oh we ask it again what do you think's
more common
um men in your situation where they
don't want to be in the kids lives or
where women don't let the dad see the
kid
I think it's a mixture of both
because if you
that's a good question
it might be more deadbeats because most
more more men like if they have in a
situation like I'm happy and they
haven't like like the encounters I'm
having with just fun sometimes you don't
want to be
um
connected to just fun so [__] that's
just casual we don't want to be
connected and that's what that child is
so it might be more babies I don't know
women because if if a woman I allow a
man to see
his child that he want to see
she is indirectly making him a deadbeat
because there's nothing he can do about
it yeah
that can turn that can turn men into
saying [__] those kids
especially the ones that want them I
feel I feel bad for the men that
actually want their kids and actually
want to be a father and and it's with a
woman
potentially like the ones that I left
behind you feel I feel bad for men like
that because there's nothing they can do
I heard somebody say to one of my uh
Partners from high school because he was
going through this [__] white boy he was
going through this and his dad told him
do as much as she allow you to do
and that just let me know man don't have
no rights for their kids bruh they ain't
got no rights to their kids and then
it's an issue when a dude like me
don't want to deal with the kids but
when a man this dude fought so hard to
to try to get even visitation like he in
jail with his child it's crazy it's it's
like it's like you you want to force
them to be fathers but you're not trying
to back or help them up once they want
to be fathers the [__] this [__] is
crazy
did you did you have a father in your
life like growing up
yeah yeah I come for both I come for
both my parents married
okay
I'm just wondering like and I'm not oh
my God God another thing I was gonna say
oh yeah two parent household oh they own
that house got some land got small
businesses you feel me but I was gonna
say too um to any parents that's even
watching this [__]
you can do the best you can do with your
children raise them however you want to
raise them it's a good chance that
they're gonna be raised up in your
mortgage but it's a it's a point in
their life that they might stray from
that [__] so parents that see they they
children being things that they didn't
teach them to be don't don't take that
[__] to Art because they have to live
their own life and they have their own
paths they're gonna walk do your parents
agree with this
oh hell no not at all not one bit but
they can't they can't control me my mom
would say if if a woman ever come and
say that's my best that's my uh
grandbaby I take the DNA test and I'll
be in their life so my parents don't be
with this but they can't control what I
do you feel me
do you think you would act differently
if women did
again would you act do you think
I'm trying to rephrase this in a better
way if we're in a more
like I'm just wondering because they
always say like women like the way that
men act are a result of the women right
so I'm just wondering if like women were
acting in a different way if you would
too
if they act in a different way yeah like
not what you mean you know not like
[__]
nah
I love [__] man I love hoes I really do
like we try to act like we don't love
hoes but we really do love hoes we just
don't want to love hoes you know what
I'm saying we love hope but don't we
just don't want to love those like for
real for real nah I think I think that's
the hypocritical thing about it because
now I have to actually get down I have
to actually take my time to get to know
a woman before she give me some [__]
[Music]
but you'd have to get to know a woman if
girls if you didn't have like girls that
were acting [__] wouldn't you like
then you probably would right
yeah you'd be forced to yeah but it's
like so in a way it's like men's
behavior in a way is our fault
you could say that you could say that I
said I said this one day I said um [__]
you right yeah yeah because it's it's
gonna it's gonna it's gonna control how
we react and act towards women when it
comes to sex when it's so easily uh uh
able to get then the women that men
ignore is the women that's not giving
this [__] up and he gonna get to a woman
you know what I'm saying we pass up to
be a woman all the time so it's just
like yeah it's a it's a
sorry keep going
oh it's a oh it's like one of them
goddamn
I can't eat like a double-edged sword
type [__] like women should women should
uh act a little bit uh more uh
I guess reserved you feel me
do you think women
ignore the nice guys do you think that's
true like the guys that would treat them
right
and like would stick around take care of
the kid
hmm
I think women ignore it ignore guys like
that because they are born
it's nice guys that add excitement to
women like but I I do think the night
most of these nice guys they probably is
born I'm a nice guy some type of way I
might not just be nice to that
particular woman so yeah yeah they they
can yeah
I don't think it's just lame dude it's
just lame dudes getting it yeah they
like me your name has [__] they get
ignored yeah
do you wanna
um blessing do you do you have The
Breakfast Club clip I was gonna see if
we could react to it are we able to do
that yeah well I was gonna see if I
could get your reaction have you seen
The Breakfast Club clip
yes yeah yeah okay I heard it I know I
know if he's a video or not
come here okay
think who got the donkey of the day
today
well just hilarious donkey today for
Monday March 6th close to a man with uh
seven kids and seven baby mamas now I
tried not to pay attention to these
people you know I'm saying I I see these
people telling these outlandish stories
on YouTube and Tick Tock because
nowadays folks is saying and doing
anything to get some attention and being
that we live in a world where nobody
cares about the truth if the LIE is more
entertaining folks just be getting
online telling these alleged stories
just to get some clicks and subscribers
now I don't know if this story is real
but the idea is and that's what I like
to discuss and critique the idea okay
the idea that digital D has like this
young man put on the FBI's internet now
as I told you this man got seven kids
and seven baby mamas but he don't take
care of none of them okay not a one why
because he said he told those young
ladies from the beginning that he don't
want them now let's go to the FBI's main
source for exhibit AIDS YouTube hear
this young man speaker now for the past
few days I've been going live telling my
story speaking my truth and a lot of
women having an issue calling me a
deadbeat because I tell them I was being
irresponsible yeah not wearing
protection but I always tell uh
women that I got pregnant that I do not
want to be a father to these children
and I offer to pay for the abortion
majority of times they'll either take
the abortion or they'll take a plan B
but only these seven have kept these
children but the crazy thing about it is
they want me to be responsible for some
children I told them I did not want so
for some years now
some of them been trying to get in
contact with me access denied cause I I
don't really know why you're trying to
get in contact with me I didn't told you
I did not want them kids we both was
irresponsible about the decisions we
made that night yeah I could have poured
out but I didn't and I ain't caterpillar
because I'm not the one they're gonna
have to carry a baby for nine months
Jesus just a woman in my opinion women
should be more careful on who they sleep
with true Porsche you just said earlier
that women need to watch what they sleep
with
[Laughter]
he's not the first man to tell somebody
to take a plan B he's not the first man
to say he don't want a child so at the
end of the day that's why we got child
support you still got to pay for this
child he need to be telling this story
in jail right around the lunch table yes
he does because just because because
scientists that you don't want to pay
for the child I mean that you should you
shouldn't have to I I feel that proper
management is essential for a healthier
life I feel this man is out here passing
along a sexually transmitted demons okay
to whoever wants them and yes this man
is a demon and they should change that
purple smiling face emoji with horns to
his face because this is true demon time
and I really wish this young man would
have made this video after baby mama
number one because if you would have
made this video after baby mama number
one then he would have never gotten the
seven baby mamas and if he did then
every single one of them deserved a baby
father they got because when the
deadbeat tells you who they are believed
him and it does amaze me that this young
man is putting the responsibility not to
get pregnant
solely on the woman yeah can I hear more
of this guy another thing is
woman that I ain't even have to do
nothing for the bad minimum but they
gave me access to their body they think
I want to be a father to a child for one
of them wait I don't even have no type
of love for these women
how do they expect me to love these
children I can offer to a pay for
abortion but at what point can I force a
woman to go get an abortion I cannot a
woman say my body my choice but I say
it's my life my choice before y'all try
to stitch this stupid like black man
this black man that I don't give up I
don't remember what he was gonna say she
say her body her baby because that's how
he feels he's done I wish you could have
saw your face when he said these girls
give me their body for the bare minimum
like what
what what
oh this guy is disgusting like one thing
I can say about Nick Cannon this man
happens
we got to bring him up don't act like
y'all didn't think the story was his
name at first you know but anyway we
populate I don't know if this man went
to school does he know what biology is
when you put the vagina and the penis
together they could make a baby that's
how it works you know what I wish I wish
that along with these big
that is very true but I feel like if he
was getting multiple STDs he wouldn't be
moving like this and that's the thing
brothers and sisters don't understand
when y'all out here you know raw dog and
randoms okay doing the DNA dance with
any and everybody you're absolutely
increasing your chances of catching uh
Gangnam civil herpes okay gone instead
for herpes is what irresponsible
Brothers should get and I wish it was
one way gonorrhea herpes okay because
you know I don't want I don't want the
woman to get it because there's one
thing if he was telling these women his
intentions before he slept with them but
he's not he's telling them after the
fact after they have been manipulated to
sleep with him I don't respect it
because you're not giving these women he
said he did shy that's what he said
after the fact though oh he didn't no I
thought he said did you get him more no
he said listen I'm gonna have sex with
you and if you get pregnant I don't want
it I didn't say that I thought he said
after they have the baby yeah I would
respect it if he did it before okay
I'm just saying man no he actually said
he'd tell you after you need to take a
plan B
oh after he done but either way he
doesn't manipulate when you feel that
drip
you know what's going to go down
why would you think that he's going to
take care of it if
if he hasn't done it okay hold on
baby seven baby mamas and seven kids the
biggest ER
a
no no I didn't hear the whole Donkey
you wanna play a game I'm not playing
again I don't feel like playing again
don't play again don't want to play a
game
nope you don't play games no you don't
want to play a game sound white to me
I'll just get curious no okay
what's his race I don't know
I have no idea I just know it doesn't
matter what his race is he's disgusting
okay okay this is terrible human
behavior he's black wow yeah I saw it
he's actually not black what is it he is
black he's [__]
the one thing I didn't understand they
were talking about why on Earth would
you think a guy is going to stick around
if he's invested because that's what you
said you invested nothing into these
women
exactly and so it's like why like that's
another thing they always take
accountability off of the women like
like we're stupid
why on Earth would you be sneaking
around if you've done nothing for them
when they when they have the uh
get paid for somebody
like uh The Breakfast Club they can't
say what the [__] they really want but I
see some of their comments and I I and I
know some of they burn their accounts
because that this is not my first time
in uh in uh media
uh dealing with goddamn [__] like this
but not for myself like they they agree
with me on the back side when nobody's
looking but on over over the waves the
Airways are being politically correct
they got to say what they gotta say so
they can Pander into the feelings of
women so I I don't understand you feel
me and I guess the girl Porsche he she's
dealing with some child support [__] you
feel me but makes a lot of money but
like I don't understand and another
thing with the child support thing it
should be some type of cap or some type
of realistic thing for for them to uh
create how much does it take to take
care of a child it's a motherfucker's
parent what Kanye West a [__]
billionaire or Kim Kardashian the bill
yeah he got to pay 200 000 in child
support like this is what I'm saying
this system is is not it's not for men
bruh and I I didn't want to be extorted
from the system from having kids with
I really don't know yeah it's me being
irresponsible yes me being mistakes yeah
I made that [__] a lot but you know
learn from it sometimes gotta learn from
it but I I wouldn't want to be exported
like that you feel me especially if I
told you that I don't want to have kids
now it's a difference when we sit down
there and and we plan to have a family
and a man step the [__] out you see me
that's a that's a that's a bigger
difference because you you was expecting
to be there you was expecting him to uh
support this child and things like that
but I
I don't feel like I'm responsible bro we
both we both was there I I do feel like
I'm responsible I don't feel like I'm
100 responsible because we both have
decisions to make it's just the outcome
is not the one that you want it because
you eventually kept the kids because you
thought you was gonna get a little money
I got that it don't work like that
yeah I I don't believe in child support
actually I feel like I just I feel like
as women if we have the power to get an
abortion we should not have child
support like I just you can as long as
that's legal I don't really understand
but I just feel like I I really don't
like it when they act like we're stupid
like that that's the thing when that
girl was saying oh like did he tell her
before did he tell her after I'm like
you I'm sorry as a girl you know you
know what like based on the investment
if you're not married like that is your
own damn fault
nobody is nobody's saying that [__] when
you're going sex oh you know I'm about
to if I get nobody's saying that [__]
that's that's I don't know why even
people even think like that did I tell
them before it says oh like I said man
this this is one of the most uh
promiscuous Nations why the [__] do I
have to manipulate any women for sex
it's not me today
did any of the women make it hard for
you to get sex any of the time that you
got pregnant
how long one date
did you even have to take him on a date
that's what I said the same day next day
and I think probably
after two days if you smash I ain't
[__] with you so [__] after two days
two if I'm taking you out on two days
okay so I probably wait by like a month
and were any of the women one day to a
month were any of the women like you
were messing with for a while or was it
just
first second time you guys hooked up
nah it's it's used it's using some quick
[__] it's usually
up to a month
up to a month okay and then um did they
suggest protection in any way like
never never not even they didn't they
didn't ask questions
not even the women that uh
uh I didn't get [__] pranked I had to
always make that conscious decision this
is just the small scenario that seemed
so big because it's their life it's a
life that came out this [__] you know
what I'm saying it's like it's live that
came out of this but ain't no woman ever
uh suggests me or to put on a damn
condom bro women not talking like that
it's a small it's a small amount of
women that that that would be talking
like that and I and I and I I put this
conversation out on
excuse me I put this conversation out on
a bunch of lies that I had and plus my
Instagram it's a bunch of men agreeing
that they have never in my life heard a
woman tell them to use protection never
this no this is very common now so that
man has to take upon himself to use
protection so women women are basically
giving men the option
to answer them however the [__] they
want to enter them ain't no man man I I
didn't have this conversation for too
long for the past two months and most
men are saying women do not require men
uh or no ain't gonna say request man to
put on a damn condom before they go in
there and that and that's Universal for
any [__] race
so these women no condom no nothing
didn't ask you to take them on a date
you weren't in a relationship with any
of them and then how then they told you
you're pregnant and you offered to play
or they told you that they were pregnant
and then you offered to pay for an
abortion for all of them and
every every different time or if if I'd
known that um
like you know what I'm saying like being
uh I guess letting off shooting out the
club you just say that [__] if I'm known
I shot a club I'm giving either cash
half of the money to get a plan b or
either body [__] myself but like I said
I'm not about to Hold Your Hand sit
there and watch you take the
[__] you know what I'm saying
it is what it is I offer every time
but at the end of the day they said yes
to sex they didn't ask for a condom they
they chose not to be on birth control
and they also chose not to take a plan B
did you offer a plan B too
they had to choose not to take the the
damn Plan B because if I known right off
the real that's the first thing you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah
you feel me so whatever agenda that you
had to think oh this baby gonna keep
this man around that I barely know [__]
that [__] got cut and short
and then on top of that they said no to
the abortion
and so how so when you told them that
they you didn't want to be a part of it
how did they react
[__] the same way the internet reacted
the same way to the internet reacted and
I'm just like not getting the same I
don't care I'm like I'm not trying to be
a father to this kid then I always say
what's my name
I always say what's my name
exactly
it's a hard truth but it's a real one
you only know my [__] name but you
want me to be a father to a child that
we accidentally had
wow
I'm sorry
um okay
well I guess at the end of the day they
had Choice one choice two choice three
Choice four Choice five I mean I still
don't get the the seven baby like you
keep saying I learned or sometimes you
live and you learn I don't know how you
live and you learn with seven
ten
but
you know at the end of the day I do
agree with you I don't really think we
put accountability on women
um and I I really don't know how you
would get pregnant by a guy where you
don't know his name like that is mad to
me
this is a different world oh my gosh
um yeah
and but you think the people on The
Breakfast Club agreed with you like
Charlemagne
oh 100
have you had any celebrities reach out
saying they agree with you
yeah care care to name them yeah
I ain't gonna do that to them she
do you think that do you think that simp
culture is the reason for the backlash
on this
yeah that's a good question
because backlash uh
I think I think because
I think the backlash is coming from most
of the women that have [__] did like
they made this [__] decision or or
might have a father you know what I'm
saying they might have a father that's a
deadbeat or they have a baby day or or
ex-husband that's to be a beat that's
what most of the bachelor the backlash I
think is coming from because they have
they they want to uh guess the I guess
take all that [__] out on me you should
you should see my DMs of people write me
long ass [__] paragraphs about how
upset and how much of a dead be I am and
I just sent that ass a laughing emoji
like I don't give a [__] you're trying
to express to me about some [__] that I
just don't care about I don't care it
can't affect me but I I let them do that
thing if I if I gotta be the world's
punching bag [__] for their mistakes
they're mine go ahead and go punch go
ahead go punch because that [__] ain't
gonna affect me at all I eat sleep well
okay and the crazy thing about it it
doesn't eliminate the amount of [__] I
get it probably rolls the [__] up
it probably rolls me just speaking out
saying this [__] I have so many more
women in my DMs and that's a fact
that's a fact
the the the the the same night that I
went on Tick Tock live with judical and
trippy
the same night
I smashed a woman that same night
telling the same story
shout out to do to kill shout out to
Trippy
that same night so I don't feel bad why
would I feel bad
that's another you're another you grown
you make your own decision you come over
here and but now I just say this
now uh I am practicing uh safe sex but
I'm doing it on a larger scale with the
uh this company out of Atlanta Georgia
uh it's a black owned company the B
condoms
so we practicing we practicing
um
or getting together to you know I'm
saying kind of like promote uh safe sex
with you know what I'm saying prevent
preventative measures of uh pregnancies
and STDs and [__] like that so
it's good things that that and I guess
they came out here somebody gonna say
man you can take that check and take
care of your kids that's
I got an Lac I got a trust I can go
ahead and yeah do what I got to do I
don't own nothing I don't got no money
you feel me
did the girl that you slept with that
night ask you to put on a condom
hey hey
no she didn't
think about it
no [__] you didn't I put one on though I
was about to laugh and that just
realized like no she really did
that's crazy
I use one though
yeah um I'd like to clarify
no just respect they're saying
um I'm justifying this
you know guys I'm not I'm not justifying
this I I think that was a bad choice you
know the seven baby mothers I wouldn't
really but guys at the end of the day
it's on the women like he's he's
absolutely right about the first part of
his videos absolutely on the women like
you guys you guys heard him these girls
required no condoms they barely knew him
they he offered them a plan B he offered
them an abortion
you know
I
I I'm not a fan of the the you know
seven baby mothers that's just a lot I
don't know how you don't learn after the
first like five you know but guys like
at the end of the day he just slept with
another girl she still didn't say to
wear a condom
it's like you know
yes it would be on them both they're
saying it's on both of them look it it
in a way yeah it sure
but like we have so many more toys you
know what I I honestly think it's like
80 on women 20 on Mad maybe I'll give 30
to men maybe 30 because it's just like
we have 10 choices they have two
abstinence or condoms we have birth
control we have plan B we have abortion
oh yeah you're right you're right
vasectomies too you're right three three
I ain't doing no damn but thank you I
ain't getting no mistake yeah
no I can't do it do you do you want kids
someday
ever
yeah I'm gonna get married and I'm gonna
have kids that I want with the woman
that I want I didn't want them so I
didn't want them kids
okay
wow
is there anything else you want to ask
him
I don't know
okay
I'm sorry
um
yeah yeah this is just this is just a
different world to me I don't know
anyone that like moves like this and in
like my real life I know some people
with the the most like baby mothers I
know is three but it's like they're
Ex-Wives so you know it's a little
you know there's like plans let's do
that yeah
yeah so I'll eliminate my family are
married
moms sisters
like I don't I don't know I don't yeah
it's just you know that's that's just
having fun [__] but it is just to put a
little bit more context this these are
not
ugly women these are not out of shape
women these are not broke women these
are not unattractive women you feel me
man if I tell you the occupations y'all
wouldn't believe it oh tell me tell me a
few uh no one up one of them the the
woman that's married she's a um
the I guess what is an orthodontist
she's an orthodontist
I think that's the uh the deal with the
teeth
oh yeah yeah whatever that is yeah she's
she's one of those so yeah I don't
remember the other jobs but I just know
these are not just women you just gonna
find Walking on a damn street you feel
me
how old were they when they got pregnant
roughly
yeah I don't know okay yeah legal age
for sure no no
um I
I was wondering if they were like we're
likes to 30 and that was maybe part of
it
in their 30s that's the question yeah
that's a good question
I've heard guys say like if they're
under 25 they're not worried because
they know that the girl won't keep it
but if she's over like 25 to 35 they
have to like be more careful I've heard
guys say that
yeah I didn't think about that I think
about that now though
yeah I never thought about it see you it
wasn't like really intentional you done
I just I ain't never thought that far
into it that's interesting
do you think you would have known
um like these girls would you have
guessed
I'm trying to think a way to phrase this
would you have guessed like they were as
like would the average guy know that
that they were [__] you know
would you say like was it not no it
wasn't obvious no probably not yeah a
few of them but probably not
I guess you gotta have a type of
confidence to pull that [__] out of them
do you think that they made that the
woman made her husband wait for sex
I don't even think he knows that's not
his child and I don't think she I don't
know
wait wait oh she was married like at the
time
yeah so he's raising a kid that's not
his
that's not his
and your shirt's yours
yeah we did a DNA test
the the little kids you buy
I don't know CVS whatever the home dma
test and [__] you got to swap you got
all that yeah and she didn't if she
didn't tell them
that's the orthodontics
I have no faith so she could she
couldn't she couldn't abort the child
because the Father the her husband would
have had some issue with why why you
aboard my child
but he ain't that's why I say bro y'all
gotta get y'all got to get DNA tests if
for anybody that'd be like hey or why
would you [__] married woman because
they're the most desirable like why did
that man go marry let me go see what
that is you say and I'm not responsible
for no for nobody uh decisions they make
even if they married
it's a lot of it's a it's a lot to
unpack
and I ain't even tell you the up man I
got hey I'm I'm safe I'm saving um
because I got a lot of a lot of a lot of
a lot of like attention right now so I
don't want to just dry it out but I'm
gonna tell the story a different story
on on
every situation
[Music]
for sure for sure for sure
they're saying you're you're seven and
oh
nah nah I'm always seven I'm three and
seven [__] here three
I'm three and seven [__]
that's a funny comment
uh cash up there who who said that God
damn
oh my God these comments are crazy
I applaud his honesty not his world how
much in child support would you owe if
they actually made you pay it a month I
have no idea
um what [__] I can I can I can uh put on
I can put that I make minimum wage
I can set up whatever I do
as if I am under I'm an employee of
under my own business and pay myself
minimum wage
see we know as much yeah if it ever come
to that day and I'll give a damn if they
seeing this [__] and trying to find yeah
you can't tell me how to you can't tell
me how to pay myself within my own
business yeah I make minimum wage and I
won't be commingling any type of fund
what
what's the craziest
um do you have any like crazy stories
from like dealing with women over the
years like any crazy
yeah I got a lot of crazy stories
I was telling I don't want to tell that
one
um
let me see
damn you should have asked me this you
should have asked me this
something someone come to mind
someone come in line
yeah I think I think the uh the woman
being a wife and getting pregnant and
can't abort the child that's probably
one of the craziest ones
but I I can just put me on spot right
there
you're gonna take a second we got time I
don't know if you're in a hurry or
something
let me see I think someone that says
lead attorney wants to call in uh you
can call in if you want
[Music]
um
just
message me I'll send you the link
um
let me send it really quick
oh okay give me one second I'm just
gonna send him the link to see if he
wants to come
uh
okay I'm gonna watch in case he wants to
come on do you know who lead attorney is
who is it no he's another YouTuber
um oh no I don't know what that is okay
sorry go ahead just
no I ain't got nothing right now right
now
my mind as soon as you ask me in my mind
my mind [__] froze
what other podcast requests have you
have you gotten to come on
I just did Antoine Daniels earlier
um
right now but it's just a few of them
though because I I want I wanted to be
uh you know I'm saying setting Stone
before it do yeah but it's it's some
it's some big ones there's some big ones
um I mean [__] yours big
the videos everywhere I actually when I
messaged you I was like oh he already
follows me I was like he's gotta
it's for sure gonna come on now
um
okay well I don't think Jamie or
um I don't like leads coming on so well
um thank you for for calling in
um we might do another one later this
week if you're free
cool yeah for sure okay I'm gonna bring
the story for you I'm gonna bring the
story I'll tell you another story about
one of my not right now though but I'm
just saying for uh
time I got you okay okay well thank you
um I don't know how to
I need you to hear
okay thank you
all right appreciate it that press was
one okay
okay guys
um
oh you know we could have did we could
have done a call-in show
I didn't even think of that
that's okay it's late anyway are you
tired
um okay
yeah guys I'd like to say
I never anywhere said it was a good idea
to get seven baby mothers never in my
life okay
um but he does have a point he
absolutely does have a point okay those
women had option one option two option
three option four they had birth control
they had
they could track their cycle all right
they could
pick better they could pick someone they
know better to make a child with at the
end of the day women are in control sex
guys and if
you know
if if we choose to make bad decisions I
just say you're [__] out of luck
honestly like we have most of the choice
when it comes to the dating market like
there there is always a guy
that is willing
to be with you and take care of your kid
if I'm being honest and we just continue
to pick
I mean you heard them we continue to
pick men that don't want to be fathers
and then we're confused when they're not
when they don't want to be fathers
um I don't advocate for this
um you know that I'm not the biggest
this was a lot this this was kind of
crazy
um but you know I do see where he's
coming from with the first half so like
the video on your way out
um we might do another stream with him
later this week so if you guys have any
ideas for that or something you want to
do let me know in the comments
um also we're trying to collect emails
um
for
we're gonna do a red pill versus blue
pill boxing event and we're also going
to do some meetups and drop some
beautiful Majestic creature merch if you
catch my dress so I'm gonna put that in
the description so like the video on
your way out so